the new head of the bureau of alcohol
tobacco firearms and explosives tells
cbs news he has a plan to tackle
america's gun violence epidemic steve
detelbeck was sworn in yesterday as the
atf's first permanent director in more
than seven years a short time later he
sat down for an exclusive interview with
cbs evening news anchor and managing
editor noah o'donnell
i think it'd be naive for me to sit here
and say to you that
i would get confirmed as atf director
and this this constant drumbeat of gun
violence is going to stop to me what we
have to do is focus on addressing the
problem it's time to push the we got to
get to work button not the panic button
will there be more uvaldis uh it's it's
just a horrible question for you to even
have to ask right but the truth of the
matter is is that there have been just
incident after incident for a long
period of time so we have to work hard
to
try to make sure there aren't but i
think the reality is there's going to be
serious gun crime
that we have to work on at atf
and you can see more of nora's interview
with steve detelbach on cbsnews.com